A next question.
Hey David, if a Pete Buddha judge wins Iowa,
could he win the nomination even if he never
takes the lead in national polling?
This is a very interesting question.
So if you look at national polling right now,
as of as of this recording, booted judges
polling just under 8%.
Now that doesn't sound like much, but it does
represent a close to doubling of Pete booted
judges polling.
If you go back just a few months, Pete, who?
Jesuit polling as low a as as about 4% he's
at nearly 8% so certainly his national support
has increased.
He has been helped, as we talked about earlier
by MSNBC.
His choice to give him way more talk time
than his polling level would dictate if talk
time correlates with polling support.
But this is an election that is a bunch of
primaries.
It is not one national election.
So let's look at the States.
If you look at Iowa, a Pete Buddha judge,
according to the last four polls, is leading
in Iowa and he surged to take the lead over
Elizabeth Warren, Bernie Sanders, and Joe
Biden, Warren Sanders and Biden, depending
on which poll, you look at our between second
and fourth P Buddha judges in the lead.
What about New Hampshire?
If you go over to New Hampshire right now,
Pete Buddha judge has made a significant gain
in New Hampshire but is not as of now in the
lead, technically still in third place, although
within the margin of error ahead of Bernie,
behind Warren and Biden.
Then you go to Nevada, which is primary number
three and in Nevada, Buddha judge at this
point appears to have no chance whatsoever.
He's pulling around five to nine and remember
that if you don't get 15% you don't get any
delegates whatsoever.
So in Nevada as of now, shaping up to be a
zero for Buddha judge.
And then when you look at South Carolina,
the first of the four primaries that has more
minority voters, Pete, Buddha, judge, also
very behind in fourth place with as little
as 3% support in one of the most recent polls.
So if Pete Buddha judge wins Iowa, can he
win the nomination?
It is not obvious to me, but he also is still
in this thing.
There are people who are big budaj supporters
who are making the case that he is sort of
on an Obama like trajectory for late gain
and that even if he's not winning right now
in Nevada and South Carolina, if he takes
Iowa, that's going to help him in New Hampshire.
If you take Iowa and New Hampshire that's
going to get a momentum and help them in Nevada
and then at least he might be able to get
some delegates out of South Carolina.
Even as unlikely as it might be that he wins
there.
The answer is yeah, he could win, but it is
a significantly uphill battle compared to
Biden, Warren and Bernie who are currently
in a position where if their elections today
mirrored their polling today, they would get
delegates.
Pete, Buddha, judge in a number of these States
would get zero delegates because he's not
pulling 15% which is required to get any delegates.
Iowa's a little different because it's a caucus
where there are sort of subsequent rounds
of consolidating support.
We don't have to get into the details of that.
So if you are a Buddha judge supporter and
you are holding out hope, yes he could still
win the nomination.
And this is why I've said it does make sense
for him to be in the debates.
It doesn't make sense for a lot of the other
people who are in the debates to be in the
debates.
If you are not a Buddha judge supporter, it
is still the most likely scenario that he
does not secure the nomination.
But it was unlikely that Trump was going to
secure the nomination at one point as well.
So let's not read more into that than is warranted.
Uh, he's in this thing and if he does win
Iowa, it will no doubt be a boost to his campaign.